how should zakat be paid on
land is it sufficient to pay zakat on it
once for a number of years when it is
sold if any land is purchased for the
purpose of selling for doing business
then zakat should be paid
2.5% of the value of the land every year
so once you possess the land and if one
year passes then you have to pay 2.5% of
the current value so whichever date you
have chosen to calculate zakat it should
not be on the price at which you
purchased the price may go up off land
the price may go down so whatever is the
present value of the land that you
possess the moment one year is completed
after you have acquired it you have to
pay zaka 2.5% on it and suppose you have
a land for several years and
you have to pay every year from whatever
other wealth you have but if you don't
have any other wealth and it's only land
that you have and you're unable to pay
the zakat paying every year is the best
but if you're unable to pay if you don't
possess any other wealth that time as a
last resort which is not recommended but
at the last resort if you don't have any
money then you can delay the paying of
zakat till the time you sell it and when
you sell it if you possess the land for
five years and you haven't paid zakat so
when you sell it you have to pay 5 into
2.5 but you have to note down the value
of the land every year the first year
the value may be X second year it may be
y third year it may be Zed so note down
the value every year and if you get 2.5%
of that value that year and you have to
add up 2.5% each year add up the five
years and then that amount you have to
give after you sell the land but the
best is to give it as soon as possible
thank you Dr Zak